hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video guys
i'm here to tell you about what is
happening in the market and as you know
this is not good guys we're going to
discuss what is happening on mcgme but
very important as well we're going to
discuss what is happening on triple q
which is the nasdaq hundred etf and
we're gonna see what is happening on the
rates and the forex market guys so let's
get into it
[Music]
okay guys so like i said technical
analysis on amc has always been tricky
but right now it's not even that it's
tricky is that you know the answer the
solution of what's going to happen is
not on amc's chart he's on
triple q u.s 10-year yield we're in a
situation where uh macroeconomics are
driving the flows all right and you
can't have massive buying flows on amc
when the rest of the market is crashing
so we're going to analyze what is
happening on amc but like i said the
answer the solution of what might happen
next is gonna be given by the technical
analysis i'm gonna do on the other chart
so here
what are we trying to do guys we are
daily timeframe we're trying to know
when finally booze are gonna take back
control right bears and full control
guys for the past month all right
roughly and there is no rebound it's
just you know
you know down down down every day so
first the good news i have is that when
booze are gonna take back control we're
gonna we should go at least to the 38.2
fib ratio of the last move down it's
true on the upside it's from the
downside all right for a move to be
corrective it needs to reach at least
the 38.2 percent so
at some point we're going to go back to
the 2122 area the question is when
and then i don't know if we're going to
go much higher or not it's going to once
again depend on what is happening on the
rest of the market so here to know when
the reversal is going to come like i
said guys we need to find so we have
some uh bullish divergence on the forest
and frame so we we see we have a
consolidation here you can see the mark
is just
converging towards inside the switch
pattern so this is
and we have very low volume so this is a
reversal situation now we need to add to
that guys a reversal signal so what is
what can be a reversal it can be a
candlestick pattern like a hammer for
example hammer is a very good reversal
signal so we can check in the past guys
we add some you know here for example
you have a nice hammer so basically here
a hammer here hammer right so
i didn't prepare this one but you can
see hammers are so once again a hammer
is a candlestick like that bam when
bears
have been trapped during the day all
right so we go lower and then we close
the day higher all right so this is a
hammer uh so if you have a nice hammer
this could be a reversal pattern but
ideally we want to have a breakout and
i'm going to show you that right now
guys what kind of pattern we're looking
for but just before i want to tell you
about something guys i posted a video
about south spot so hotspot is an
amazing nft project guys that
collaborated with us with crypto booze
thanks to them guys we are right now
booming we took like 2 300 followers
because their followers base is amazing
so go watch this video guys because uh
once again it's important for the
projects that they have used go like and
comment guys last time i asked you a lot
of you did it but you can do better than
that and comment guys show them that our
community is strong and once again it's
good for the project and it's good for
you as well for those who have not
joined crypto bus this code
already do it now i secured around 200
early bull spot for you guys okay i kept
them but i can tell that right now we're
growing fast guys so i can keep them but
you need to tell me that you want it
otherwise i will give it to someone else
but don't worry i still have some for
you so you can basically buy an nft
crypto bull at 100 us dollars and then
we're going to sell it 200 and then 300
and i can tell you i can see that we're
going to be sold out guys within uh
maybe six months we're gonna do our last
mint at 300 us dollars and
the hype we're having right now thanks
to sol spot because their project is
amazing and their investors are very
very excited and they are like very
strong nfc investors and they just you
know arrived on the crypto bus discord
guys and they made the and it was fire
for like a few hours so thank you very
much guys i really want all of you to go
there uh give me like 200 likes 300
likes on this video guys it's important
don't forget to comment the link of the
video to like and comment is in the
description let's go back to amc guys uh
because i i know i'm in the nfcs but
guys the real deal is amc of course at
the right time guys i'm gonna increase
my position and let's see guys we are in
a situation let's be honest where it's
hard to say if this squeeze will happen
or not and as long as we are in a
bearish environment the screws won't
happen all right but the same way i tell
you guys that some spots is very hot is
because i can see the follower's base i
went to the discord i went to the
twitter i can see the engagement and i
feel the exact same thing about amc this
is the reason why i do amc videos guys
it's because you guys are crazy about ac
you love amc i love amc and there is a
strong strong community around the stack
because it represents not only a stock
it represents a movement it's a fight
between retail investors and the big
money players hedge fund asset managers
that are not respecting the rules all
right so we know why we fight and this
fight is not over and this is the reason
why i believe that great things can
happen on amc even if right now let's be
honest there is maybe more than said to
come i don't know but this is long term
play so whatever let's go back to the
technicals so here candlestick hammer
like i said it can be a bullish engel
thing maybe we have some okay here we
have a booty oh nice this is a hammer
and a bullish angle thing okay it's it's
not a bullish enough thing a bullish
engine thing is whenever here is a
bullish angle thing so it didn't give us
a nice signal so basically it's when one
candle engulfs totally the one before
which means that once again bears have
been trapped during the day okay so
bullish engulfing a hammer whatever or a
breakout i personally prefer breakouts
and here you can see guys
let's zoom in a little bit let's go fast
and frame and you guys can see that uh
we're having a very nice wedge pattern
all right uh here like once again the
wedge has moved guys let's be honest the
wedge was like that at the beginning it
was like that then we had here downside
breakout so you need to adjust your
wedge that's the tricky thing with
wedges that's why
if you don't if you see a wedge and a
bullish divergence it's not the right
time to buy you need to wait because as
you can see the wedge can transform into
deeper wedge you need to wait for
bullish signal candlestick pattern
breakout moving average crossover you
can see here the moving averages are
very distant they're not even closing or
at least the price action
crossing the 20-day moving average of
the training period you know where is
the 20 day trading days is a good
indicator of that the 20 days very high
but at least the 20 period moving
average on the first time frame so
whatever but something bullish right we
don't have it so it's not the right time
to increase the position but we are
close to that guys as you can see both
are putting pressure so i know we are
moving lower you don't maybe i mean if
you look at the chart you don't feel
like bulls are actually putting pressure
but
uh the truth is that they are because
look how many times they tried to break
out above this trend line so one two
three four okay four times and we are
really sticked to this uh upper band
wedge upper bend alright and you can see
here the connection are very good
so we can go lower guys we can very well
you know stay in that all right it's
possible and just keep you know grinding
lower on low volume that's one scenario
there is another scenario that will
break out okay with increasing volume
yeah it's very important if you don't
see the increase in volume this breakout
is likely to fake out i personally
bought a lot of breakouts without volume
increase on amc because i don't want to
miss the move up
because i i'm following let's be honest
on emc i'm following you
but you should not do that you should
wait for a volume increase to happen
with a breakout so right now the bracket
level is around 15.8 so the good thing
is that the the more we wait the lower
we we can buy this bracket what's gonna
happen after the breakout probably a
move towards the 21 area oh right jimmy
so jimmy guys
is has reached so once again you can see
the correction is uh totally fine we
only arrive to the 61.8 percent feeb
ratio so this was a little bit expected
since we broke out below 140 i told you
guys that we are going there we did so
now we reached this level so bears might
let it go we can do the same kind of
trend line with gme so let's zoom in
and you can see we're a little bit in
the same situation so we don't have the
buddhist divergence here okay let me get
rid of this one just for the this
analysis okay
so here how many reactions it's not as
good this trendline is not as good as
the one i have on mc because i have less
reactions but still
if we break out above that with volume
increase this would be looking good
and very quickly for those who didn't
watch amc part guys i'm asking you once
again for crypto bull nft project to
go in the description click on the video
about south spot like it commented guys
it's very important for me and it's good
for you if you join crypto booze once
again because i secured some early bull
spot for you come to me claim it and we
it's gonna be good for everybody so then
jimmy
once again here we are waiting for a
move i would say we need to take back
the 102d level the situation is a little
bit different let's be honest look the
consolidation is here all right so once
again gm is stronger guys
look amc
it's consolidating but dropping all
right the consideration is i would say
here right
gme
it's a flat-ish consolidation so you can
see
i mean it's pretty much the same things
but when amc is dropping gme is flat so
here the consideration is here so what
we need is a move above this 120 level
uh this would be a short-term bullish
signal once again it needs to happen
with increasing volume if this happens
what can we expect either it's just a
dead cat bounce which means we would go
probably to the 150 area
okay
or
it is the third wave it's possible so
let's now discuss this scenario so for a
third wave to happen on amc jamie which
means that basically they're going to
take a few hundred persons all right so
we're talking about a massive massive
move up with crazy volume so for this
creative volume to be here we need asset
managers we need hedge funds we need
algorithms we need every market players
to be in the trade those market players
they're not going to buy mcn gme if the
rest of the market is crashing so
do we have a chance that we're gonna
have a rebound here so as you guys know
i'm bearish since we broke out below
338. uh i'm having a short position that
is covering my long positions some i
even made a little bit of money
but i just want to be flatish here i
tried to increase my bearish position
but let's be honest it happened very
quickly and i didn't actually take a
bearish position here what i'm targeting
is this trendline all right so i'm
having some selling orders that are
placed here so i didn't get executed i
hesitated to target this trend line i
showed you that guys in the previous
video this trendline that is a good
trend line and i told you that it was
resistance then support now resistance
again and you can see so it's
interesting look at that guys to have a
trend line that is crushed you know not
respected but it's still acting as a
trend line so it's not happening all the
time so you need to check if the strain
line is visible or not and here we had a
hint so i have some regrets because we
so
i know i don't have regrets
i know that right now it's acting as
resistance because it acted here
perfectly as you can see as resistance
and here i could have sold and in my
previous video i told you that we're
gonna sell here and here but i didn't
sell here why i don't know i just felt
that we have more upside and i i didn't
want to take this i was a little bullish
maybe you know deep in myself deep
inside and i i want you to wait for this
trend line to be touched to take a
bearish position here so i'm still
bearish i mean i'm still having a short
position on triple q which is protecting
me but i don't make money on the
downside it's always good to make money
so that you can reload you know more at
the right time so two questions how low
can we go are we bearish
on the long term and what is gonna give
us a rebound so i'm going to answer all
of these questions first question is are
we bearish so we broke out below the 318
level but for the second time i'm still
having here some hope with this trend
land which is not perfect i
even destroy line is broken so we are
bearish guys we are bearish what can
happen here we have this volume increase
it's not crazy volume yet we are bearish
here maybe we're gonna retest this so i
said that if we have a breakout below
this i will take a bearish position here
so i will see you guys
i'm a bit scared to take a bearish
position here because we've seen the
rebounds that are very strong too so of
course i would use a stop loss but you
know you can i prefer to wait for this
all right and then he'll take a bearish
position i don't know i'm gonna see how
i uh fill the market on monday maybe i'm
gonna enter on the bearish position
around 3 18. so for s triple q it's
around 47 you know so maybe i'm gonna
take a bearish position here i don't
know we're gonna see i prefer to wait
for this yellow trendline to be honest
it's safer all right so first question
are we bearish yes we are because we
broke out below the stream land we broke
out below 318 and i'm gonna show you
that guys we have increasing volume on
downside so it's not good what can we
expect so i'm gonna make quickly a few
scenarios so what we want all right is
clearly a breakout above this yellow
trend line that would be the first
bullish signal all right so maybe this
is a fake out it's possible so what we
want is to see the price action coming
here and here all right if we go above
338
boos are gonna take back control on the
medium term which is going to be good
for amc good for jimmy uh first scenario
second scenario so something like that
it's not the perfect scenario second
scenario uh bearish we just come back to
318 quickly and drop all right i think
that's okay if we just start to really
make new lows which we are doing the
real
level is 280 guys so this is the level
where we're gonna have i think a strong
bounce okay so this is what i'm gonna
play i'm personally gonna buy i had some
questions in my discord why didn't you
buy here on uh when we had the rebound
all right before the rebound my answer
was because we were bearish and
unfortunately i was right i didn't buy
here because it was the third time we
are testing this support guys first time
you can buy second time careful third
time don't buy a support that has been
tested three times in the recent past
it's just i mean suicide all right i
mean you could have bought it but take
profit quickly uh unfortunately the
third time was the right one and right
right now we're dropping so if we arrive
here maybe we're gonna go lower maybe
it's gonna be a massive crisis i don't
know but even in massive market drops we
see strong rebounds remember the coveted
crisis we were moving down 10 percent up
8
so i'm going to play this here i'm going
to be a massive massive buyer without
stop loss i think i'm just going to
accumulate if we arrive strongly because
at some point there's going to be a
strong bounce all right so this is my
strategy for the uh bearish case
if we have a breakout here i might buy
the retest here and once again when i'm
paying attention to you guys and i told
you about that and it's not looking good
guys u.s 10-year yield which is
representing the inflation which is the
return expected return of equity that
companies need to beat so the higher it
is the tougher it is for companies to
make more money than this yield so
investor prefer to store the money and
get a yield then buying equity right it
makes sense so the higher it goes the
the worse it's going to be
uh and right now we have a 40-year
resistance guys that has been broken
last week on a weekly time frame and i
told you guys that if this breakout gets
confirmed it's not going to be good and
it is confirmed i don't want to be
bearish like you know we're going to
have something really bad happening but
unfortunately
i have bad signals coming from that i
still have some hope that this is just
some excess the good thing is that we
are not
clearly far above we're not at 3 30 but
it's the second week we close above 285
uh once again my friend at gomo sax told
me that if the if we go above three so
this is their level uh they're gonna
start to tell their big clients to
decrease the investment in equity okay
so i think that this is what is
happening right now i think that we are
at the crossroads of two
major scenarios a bull market or bear
market all right and everything is going
to happen in the coming days weeks right
we can still have here a strong
rejection uh you can see dx y i told you
as well guys uh dollar index a rush for
the dollar is not good for the economy
because it shows it creates tensions and
it shows fear so two reasons for this
indicator to be one we need to keep an
eye on and i told you the 103 level was
resistance and i told you i don't want
to see a breakout above that level we
had a breakout on the daily time frame
and it got rejected so maybe it's a fake
out all right i don't see the volume so
if it was a low volume i would say most
likely a fake out but it's still a
second close above the level guys so we
have the two indicators that i told you
to pay attention to yes that both giving
us bad signals so once again it's really
on the limit so there is still a chance
that we got rejected here got rejected
here and and have a massive rebound here
after some access it's still possible
all right and i really want this to
happen i i strongly hope this will
happen but
the situation is that i don't have
control you don't have control the
united states don't have control this is
about investors
psychology about what they feel and
let's be honest guys the war with russia
is not looking good right biden unlocked
30 billion us dollars to help ukraine in
which 20 billion is going to be used for
weapons
guys the third world war has started all
right it's not is it gonna start it has
started let's be honest we are in war i
mean it's russia china not we don't
really know but maybe a little bit with
russia against us europe united states
all right that's the war for now it's an
economic war but i mean i'm personally
scared all right about what can happen
i'm not scared for my life
or something but i'm scared about the
situation i don't see how the situation
can be good the only way it gets good is
that putin gets away from the picture
which is not gonna happen unless someone
somebody kills him i'm not calling for
that but it's one way things can go
better or there is a revolution in
russia i don't know there are some
solutions but we've put in in power i
don't see a solution
so
maybe i'm not the only one to think like
that that's why guys i want to be
bullish but i'm a bit bearish right when
i look at macroeconomics you know the
rates are just going higher and we
cannot you know lower them when we need
it it is the first time is in recent
history that we can't do that because if
we do not raise the the rates the
inflation is going to kill us
so i don't know how the fed is going to
do to save us again maybe they will i
really do hope so so let's see guys
let's see and all markets uh still
bullish guys we're probably gonna uh go
to the 140 area very soon so that's it
for today i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys